i'm very very disappointed about that
reaction
you don't exactly have them shaking in
their boots i see we're
trying to get that doesn't sound like
unity you cannot cut off
the dialogue with russia but you need to
be very clear and that's what we are
for years berlin's foreign policy line
has been dialogue first
keep talking no matter what but as
russian opposition leader alexei navalny
recovers in a german hospital after an
apparent poisoning in siberia
berlin is under increasing pressure to
respond with unprecedented strength
by cancelling or pausing the nearly
completed nordstream 2
gas pipeline with russia my guest this
week is germany's deputy foreign
minister niels anand
is it time for a tougher stance against
authoritarians in russia and beyond
even if there's a financial cost
german minister of state niels anand
welcome to conflict zone
happy to have you tess confirmed that
alexia navalny
was poisoned with the military-grade
chemical weapon novichok the german
chancellor she has demanded answers from
russia she says the following
there are very difficult questions that
only the russian government can answer
and must answer the russian response has
been defiant will there be
meaningful sanctions well i i
still hope that we can prevent this but
this is entirely
the russian government's decision and i
have to say and i want to be very clear
i'm
very very disappointed about that
reaction
because instead of making clear what
happened
and to cooperate in an investigation
we are seeing the old scheme you know of
misleading information
of counter-accusations so if that is
the spirit of the russian government
then i'm afraid we are going to see this
but we are still
in a negotiation so you say it's in in
the russian government's hands um in
fact
you've called for an investigation in
russia but the foreign minister says
there are several indications russia was
behind
the attack you're asking russia to
investigate
what do you expect well look there is a
procedure here
and you mentioned that indeed it looks
like and we are
we are certain that it has been a poison
from the novichok group
and actually right now it's not only a
german
investigation we gave the probe also
to laboratories in sweden and france and
we also gave it to the opcw
so it is quite obvious
that this is a breach of international
law so i i think we are talking
not only about a tragedy involving
mr navalny this is has an international
dimension
so russia is in a position and
has the ability to clarify what happened
but but we also in in our intention to
defend the international procedures
i think we need to have that process
here and the process is not over
but in that process mr and they're not
taking you seriously are they i mean
just let's just look at some of the
rhetoric
coming from the foreign minister we
think we have an international reaction
this is not reduced to germany there's a
clear statement from the european union
the world
takes notice so i don't think they don't
take a series
i just think that they're falling back
into what we know
is the typical russian here are their
words foreign minister lavrov
accused western officials of quote
putting themselves above the law
with um unsubstantiated accusations
against moscow
over the poisoning of navalny we also
have a statement from
the foreign ministry saying berlin is
bluffing serving a dirty political
agenda
you don't exactly have them shaking in
their boots look that's but
but this is just confirming what i tried
to tell you
that we are very disappointed to see you
know
the old way of reacting to accusations
instead of really engaging and i am sure
it is the russian credibility that will
be
be infringed by this so we are
united in the european union we feel
very encouraged by the international
reaction and we are not only talking
about this case
it's not the only case of poisoning of
an opposition leader
we are talking about the serious step to
undermining
what has been a more or less successful
international convention on chemical
weapons so uh i i think
we are not at the end here and except
you think russia might be violating it
and and the russian side needs to know
that clear sanctions
are on the table let's talk about you
mentioned an old way of doing things
from from the russians let's talk about
the way that you have been doing things
um i asked you about meaningful
sanctions because we know that sanctions
are already in place of course
since 2014 since the russian invasion of
crimea
but since then we have seen further
aggression from russia we've seen the
hacking attacks on the german parliament
in 2015.
we've seen the assassination of a
chechen rebel in broad daylight
in central berlin last year following
that murder
your foreign ministry you reportedly
submitted 17 requests for assistance in
solving that murder
and received not a single response
is just sanctions really going to
pressure
russia in the way that you need to well
look i'm i'm
very happy indeed that you mentioned
those incidents
i'm sitting here as the minister of
state but i'm also a member of the
german parliament
so what happened there was the hacking
attack as a serious
serious violation of our way to deal
among countries that should have a
friendly relationship
and many other incidents also see the
targeted use
you know of of hybrid measures of fake
news the troll factories that we are
seeing
that is all part of the reality
but it's also part of the reality that
we don't have
we don't have a remote control to
influence russian policies
decisions are taken in moscow not in
berlin
but what is important here and i think
we are making progress that the european
union speaks with one voice
that the russian side now said is there
a surprise to pay but that we also need
to be
realistic we need russia to solve
great many of issues concerning our own
neighborhood our stability
so i think our approach to do both
to be very clear but also engage russia
i cannot really see an alternative to
that let's talk about the voice though
that you're speaking with
because you have the nearly completed
nordstrom 2
pipeline which is set to bring more
russian gas to germany
and i'd like to ask you do you think
that putin really takes
your threat of meaningful sanctions
meaningful consequences seriously
when you have such a profitable economic
project right on his doorstep well
that that only shows how complex our
relationship
is i want to be also a little
provocative
in my answer here because i'm not so
sure of stopping that project north
stream too but which by the way is not
an initiative of the german government
it is by
it's supported by the german government
it is by definition it's supported by
the german government
let's put that aside but you know
would we do something that really would
make russia pay a price or would we also
somehow do something that goes against
our own
long-term interest so that's why i'm not
so convinced i understand
this is and has always been a
controversial issue
but it's maybe too easy just to reduce
our political toolbox on the question
whether or not
we should continue north stream to i am
with all respect not convinced that this
is the only answer that we should get so
you've turned to your partners now
your partners including in the the eu
including
also the united states and you've asked
them you want to put forward a joint
response
but they've always had problems with
this project haven't they many
among them have had problems with this
project partners have expressed security
concerns
that nordstrom 2 would allow putin to
cut off gas supply
to former soviet bloc countries without
affecting flows to the west
cut off ukraine potentially where 40 of
the natural gas imported by the eu from
russia
flows through nordstream one do you
neglect
your own partners concerns look there
are two things i want to tell you
one thing is that it would maybe
surprise you
and our viewers that the european union
is much more united on this than
you maybe think we had a uh
polish prime minister yeah well he says
this reaction should lead first of all
to the stoppage of work of nordstrom 2
which strengthens russian power
not 16 meps back in 2018
but you know you pleaded me choose the
european way
not the germany way first but you need
to let that doesn't sound like unity you
need to let me complete that sentence
because
we had 24 european member states
supporting a political dimash in
washington
raising concerns about the american
reaction
which is threatening with extra
territorial sanction
our sovereign decision about our energy
supply
just for a second think about the
european union
would put in place a law sanctioning
american companies
just let me pick one example for example
the
the astonishing fact that nobody speaks
about
the americans right now buying oil from
russia
almost and the volume that we are buying
gas
uh from russia so you know we we need to
look
at the factory and the second part is
german government at the top the
chancellor and the foreign minister
have been engaged and are engaged to
safeguard ukraine's core interest
the the deal that we signed the european
union broker but de facto was
brokered by our government between
ukraine
on the one hand and the russian
federation on the other hand
made sure that key concerns of our
partners within the european union
and in kiev have been implemented so
as i said it's too simple just to say
closing north stream two will solve the
problem
if if if anyone really believes that
you're going to take a hard line on
russia though ultimately when push comes
to shove even when it does come to
ukraine because for example
you and the foreign minister michael
moss you're both spd politicians
sure um in the spd in the spd
um there are many who are strongly
opposed
to halting the construction of this
pipeline for example we have
pipeline from russia to germany should
not be used to punish moscow over the
poisoning
of a kremlin critic alexi navalny the
sudha to saitung has called the spd the
nordstrom party
they have a point don't they they say
that they say that you're motivated by a
traditional
empathy with russia no they don't have a
point i i like to remind you
you know we are used as social democrats
and we are proud
serving here in our positions we are
somehow
getting used to this kind of accusation
but it doesn't make them correct
you know energy policy of course is
highly
political we need to make sure that
there's a clear mix
between renewables we need a breaching
technology gas is much more efficient
and less
harm to the environment we have to
address an elephant in the room sure
because we were talking about the spd
we were talking about your party and its
relationship with russia the elephant of
the room of course when we talk about
north stream
is gerhard schroeder former chancellor
former spd head
chairman of the project the wall street
journal called schroeder
putin's most important oligarch the the
wall street
you feel comfortable with that do you
feel comfortable with that putin's most
important oligarch the wall street
journal has traditionally been
maybe not the most sympathetic to the
social democrats but i'll tell you
something i have been maybe the most
vocal critic of gertrude's policy
and you know he is somebody who needs to
accept that there's public criticism
for private decision he takes but he's a
private citizen he's not sitting in
any body of cspd so the svd cannot be
blamed for what gertrude
is it really realistic though that he's
a private citizen absolutely it is okay
so he's a private citizen
so we were talking about meaningful
sanctions yeah part of the meaningful
sanctions was that there would be
targeted sanctions against individuals
correct
yes so therefore if he's just a private
person
working for putin should he be among the
individuals
who might be targeted in a sanctions
regime
yes as a result of the poisoning
of alexi i i i see we're trying to get
me
but i'm not going to defend the private
decision
by a former translator who in other
parts
i think has has been very successful and
important for germany
he always knew if you want to exert
maximum pressure on russia
maximum pressure but but this is uh
what he's doing with north stream is
he's filling a seat
um for european companies so
you know and there's always that
naturalness as that
narrative that this is only a german
project there are actually
companies from other european
partners also involved so i i really
think we're now spending
and it's your questions i'm trying to
answer that's okay with me but we are
spending more time talking about north
stream too right now
then we are spending time on talking
about our difficult relationship with
russia
and i also want to again remind part of
the relationship with russia
of course and i said you're increasing
the economic ties with russia
it is a complex relationship you know
our american friends they have an
ocean between them and russia
we don't we have a joint and shared
history
russia is not going to go away and the
decision about where russia is heading
may be influenced by us that's a russian
decision
so we are talking about peace in libya
you need to talk with russia
we're talking about peace in syria like
it or not
you need to talk with russia and there
are many other aspects so
we are trying so dialogue dialogue no
matter what
dialogue we are trying to the cost no
matter what russia does no no we
this is very important to me because
it's really
what i believe in is that
we are in a world where apparently many
of the established rules
are not binding countries like russia
unfortunately even sometimes
countries that we are more close to so
germany is in a central position
geographically
in europe it's the most important
economy
we are not you know projecting military
power
so we are we need to rely on the
willingness and ability to apply by
those rules and that's what we are
trying so you cannot cut off
the dialogue with russia but you need to
be very clear and that's what we are
let's talk about another country where
you have a lot of dialogue we have to
mention let's go to china now
sure also in the news for its continued
infringement of human rights and rule of
law
similar to russia in a speech before the
parliament on september 10th you said
the following
human rights are a central element of
our china policy
how's that working out for the
pro-democracy protesters in hong kong
well we are
and i hope that i'm not going you know
it's not i'm not intending to
to criticize any of our european
partners
but i really think sometimes
we need as a government explain more
what we are doing
i think germany is maybe the only
relevant country right now that is
addressing human rights issues with
china
on every high level meetings that we're
having
sometimes we do that publicly sometimes
don't
we don't do that publicly because we're
talking about individual cases we have
an established human rights dialogue
and and quite frankly we tried to
celebrate
a eu china summit in order to generate
more european unity also on human rights
but let's talk about the message that
you are sending you might have the
dialogue but
the message the real message that you're
sending how can china really believe
that you are serious on human rights
when in every state visit
you show up with a huge business
delegation and i'd just like to go to
the to the last one
with the german chancellor angela merkel
that was in september of 2019 where amid
the crackdown
on the pro-democracy protesters in hong
kong
she sat along the chinese premiere and
in her visit it was crowned by
overseeing the signing of
13 business deals between german and
chinese executives
in the great hall of the people in
tiananmen square
is it trade over human rights because
that's what it looks like
i don't think that it looks like this i
don't see
that this is a contradiction
i mean if if the policy would be
to completely exclude china
from our political landscape and from
our political thinking
well i think we are not going to serve
our own interests here and i am very
concerned
that this is going to happen if we are
listening to some of the
very inflammatory rhetoric right now
we need to avoid falling back into the
logic of a new cold war
but you ask about the effectiveness of
our policies
and i can tell you that there are many
cases
and some are prominent cases like the
widow of the nobel prize winner
who came into freedom and could leave
the country
because of very very high level
interventions from germany
and there are that's not always the case
is it
there and i'd like to i'd like to bring
in yeah i just want to say
that there is and i mean we cannot
ignore that
there is a temptation for many leaders
around the world
not to do that what we are doing is
german government because they believe
that if they don't address human rights
issues
that are maybe going to be speaking and
that's not what we are doing and i'm
very proud of it philosophically
speaking
when we look at your overall diplomatic
strategy we have for example your
economy minister
saying just back in july in a
conversation with politico he said i
still believe in
transformation through trade
transformation through trade when it
comes to china
your own german industry association has
come out
and said they published a paper last
year calling for a tougher approach to
china
their message was the west strategy for
opening china
has failed yeah this is a wake-up call
that they have said
in the case of china isn't it isn't it
both outdated and naive
to think you're going to have
transformation it's not happening can i
make one comment because
you were really asking me insisting on
the question of
me and my boss psycho mars being members
of the social democratic party
so um so now you're trying to put me
into responsibility for something well
you're part of the government
you're part of the government with your
christian democratic partners and i can
tell you that
i think we had maybe a decade
where we were social democrats and
christian democrats and liberals and
greens or whatever
may be too optimistic about the impact
of our economic engagements on democracy
and human rights
i think this is very obvious china
changed
the the guiding policies of deng
xiaoping
so to to bide your time never takes the
lead
that is over with mr president xi and
that's why we're in the midst
and that's why i welcome your question
we are in the midst of a debate
how to readjust our china policy and i
think we need to defend our okay
stronger but we shouldn't cut off our
ties with china
you need allies to deal with china and
russia you absolutely do let's look at
the state of your alliances right now
the us is pulling 12 000 troops out of
germany it's reportedly because you
didn't meet your defense spending goals
the nato two percent goal of gdp for
defense spending
what does it say about the state of your
diplomacy
um that this announcement reportedly
first of all caught you by surprise
shouldn't you have seen it coming from
the
they said they would well there would be
consequences well look
i mean um we don't believe
that reducing troops in germany
is an instrument to harm germany or to
to castigate germany those troops if you
look
carefully about what they are doing they
are serving
the interests of the united states armed
forces and they are part of a deterrent
where not only germany is benefiting but
europe as a whole
so we had some problems to understand
uh the logic behind that decision but it
is an energy what's the problem to
understand you're not spending two
percent of gdp you're not on track to
spending two percent of gdp this is a
commitment that you made to your allies
at a nato summit in wales in 2014
a commitment that look if you don't
appear to be intent on fulfilling
well the numbers of the appropriations
that we made
in terms of defense spending they are no
secret
they are well known in washington so if
they look at what we are doing
it's clear that we are on that we are on
track to quote
you that we are massively increasing our
defense spending but by the way not
because somebody in the united states is
demanding that from us
but because we see that the world is
changing
that we talked about it russia is
getting more assertive
we have conflicts in our own
neighborhoods that's the reason why we
are doing this
and and so i i think we cannot neglect
that we have
political differences there is a very
you know i'm in the foreign ministry
here so i
this is a unique style of the american
president
but the basis of our relationship is
stronger than
but ultimately between us ultimately
when we look at the big picture
when we look at the broad picture when
we look at the actions not just the talk
but the actions that your government and
your country is taking you're adhering
to deals in russia
the north stream to your project which
is profitable
do you want us to restart the discussion
again
we discussed it also you have you have a
very robust trade relationship with
china
um that is increasing countries where
there are open human rights offenders um
but you're not fulfilling your
commitments to allies
like nato for example when it comes to
increasing defense spending is this
really the way forward
for german diplomacy is this really what
takes you into the next decades and
beyond
look we are nato
so we are doing this because of our own
interest
it's german fighter planes right now
that are defending
the baltic skies it's german soldiers
who are part of the very high readiness
joint task force
it's a german initiative that we took up
and we are going to build a new nato
headquarters
so nobody needs to to teach us about how
important nato is
and i tell you something sometimes our
friends and allies i don't want to name
countries here
but sometimes friends and allies they
simply assume that the german would
react in the way we do how how are we
doing this
rational we're not going to be provoked
uh we're not cutting our dialogue and
the networks that we have been building
this is important for you so i'm
i'm happy to take some blame they are
sometimes disappointment
people sometimes have that strange idea
that it's
weakness not to respond in kind but we
are the force that is keeping all this
together german minister of state niels
anand thank you for joining us on
conflict zone
thank you so much
[Music]
so
you